le dernier acte d'une histoire dont la
conclusion est attendue avec impatience
le témoignage du premier ministre du
Canada
ultime témoin de la Commission sur
l'état d'urgence
mesure de sécurité accrue Jean
dudupublique et membre de la presse tout
est en place pour entendre Justin
Trudeau justifier sa décision d'invoquer
la Loi sur les mesures d'urgence aux
voyelles que il y avait une intensité
potentielle
qui était là pendant la campagne
électorale des craintes qui se sont
avérées
il y a eu le blocage d'une autoroute à
coups en Alberta ou la GRC finira par
découvrir une cage d'armes et où le SCRS
a identifié des manifestants aux
idéologies extrémistes violentes
s'ajoute à cela à la barricade du pont
ambassadeur à Windsor la présence
d'enfants qui auraient pu servir de
bouclier humain et des corps policiers
dans certains cas dépassés par les
événements qui avaient une urgence
d'agir et que
l'outil qu'on avait pour amener
rapidement
ces outils spécifiques c'était la Loi
sur les mesures d'urgence il y avait
pourtant ce plan d'intervention qui
impliquait différents corps policiers et
qui selon la commissaire de la GRC
aurait pu éviter le recours à la Loi sur
les mesures d'urgence
je conseille aux gens de regarder ce
plan qui en fait n'en n'est pas un
affirme Justin Trudeau
mais le document est caviaret fait
valoir l'avocat de la kinéine quand
c'est touche une Foundation
vous dites que nous devrions lire ce
plan vous serez d'accord que nous ne
pouvons pas le faire
juste un Trudeau ajoute qu'il y avait
consensus au sein de son cabinet et
entre les conseillers en sécurité et du
SARS
le devoir d'un Premier ministre et de
prendre des décisions difficiles et
d'assurer la sécurité de la population
je pense
après avoir entendu 76 témoins en 31
jours la Commission se tiendra la
semaine prochaine des tables rondes avec
des experts pour discuter entre autres
de pouvoir policiers et de liberté
d'expression la conclusion appartiendra
ensuite au commissaire rouleau son
rapport final est attendu au plus tard
le 6 février ici Valérie Michael
Ottawa